How Much Land do You Really Own Above and
Below Your Property?
On paper, the concept of land ownership sounds
very simple- you pay money and in return you’re
given unfettered access to a predetermined
amount of land.
But how much of that land do you actually
own?
Do you own the sky above it?
How about the land below it?
What about all the animals that may live there;
do you own those too?
All of these questions and more define what
exactly it means to “own” a piece of land.
Surprisingly, many of the answers aren’t
well defined from a legal standpoint as you’ll
soon see.
(Note: The laws governing one’s rights as
a landowner vary considerably depending on
location, even within a given country or state.
With that caveat noted, we’ll endeavor to
answer the above questions and a couple more
in the general case for places like the United
States and the UK.)
First of all, let’s deal with how much of
the air above your property you own since
that particular question has been one of the
more common queries about owning or buying
land we’ve received here at Today I Found
Out over the years.
Historically speaking, if you owned a piece
of land, you owned everything both above and
below the soil from the deepest reaches of
the Earth right up to the heavens themselves,
giving you a near infinite amount of property
in the universe with your property ever changing
as the Earth rotates and the various celestial
bodies move around.
A popular maxim in regards to this concept
is, “Cuius est solum, eius est usque ad
coelum et ad inferos” which basically translates
to: “whoever owns the soil, holds title
all the way up to the heavens and down to
the depths of hell“.
Within the legal world, this maxim is described
as “the traditional starting point of property
law” and it is considered to have been instrumental
in shaping what we understand as property
law today.
Curiously, despite its ancient sounding nature,
the specific maxim can only be traced as far
back as the 13th century and it is largely
believed to have been the brainchild of Italian
scholar, Accursius.
It’s commonly assumed that the maxim made
its way into English and subsequently American
law thanks to Accurius’ son, who was invited
to England to teach law at the request of
the then King, Edward I.
Its first use in court is attributed to the
case of Bury V Pope in 1587, during which
the maxim was cited as justification for a
large structure being erected that blocked
out the natural light to another property
owner’s home.
Since back in those days there was no such
thing as the “right to light” (essentially
the right to not have the flow of natural
light to your home impeded), it was decided
that the building of the structure was entirely
legal, since the owner of the land owned all
of the air above his land too.
Today, the maxim is still used as a guideline.
However, as a property owner you only really
have the right to the airspace above your
land located in the lower stratum, the precise
boundaries of which are not explicitly labelled.
In the end, you are supposed to be entitled
to enough airspace to reasonably enjoy the
land below that air.
However, exactly what this means is up for
debate.
For example, you can’t ask commercial planes
to stop flying over your house, because the
sky is considered to be a public highway.
You could potentially, however, prosecute
an overzealous news helicopter for hovering
over your house if it was impeding your enjoyment
of the land.
Again, this would vary on a case-by-case basis
but there have been instances of people being
fined for trespassing for flying over someone’s
land; so it’s not unheard of in US or British
law.
The most famous case of this kind comes from
1945 when a chicken farmer named Thomas Lee
Causby sued the US government for flying approximately
83 feet above his property, the noise of which
caused a bunch of Causby’s chicken’s to
accidentally kill themselves by running into
walls.
Causby won his case and the courts agreed
that although a property owner wasn’t entitled
to own all of the air above their land, they
were entitled to enough so that planes flying
overhead wouldn’t kill their chickens.
Progress!
Today in the UK thanks to the Civil Aviation
Act of 1982, the generally accepted amount
of air above one’s roof a person is entitled
to is approximately 500-1,000 feet, though
again this isn’t a hard definition.
Likewise, the United States has a similar
estimation of about 500 feet, though this
has never been officially ruled on by the
Supreme Court.
In both cases, this may be soon changing with
the widespread introduction of drones, both
personal, commercial, and those owned by the
respective governments.
As such, the U.S. federal government particularly
has recently been looking into significantly
lowering the airspace “public highway”
floor to accommodate this type of aircraft.
With that out of the way, what about the earth
below your land?
Well, again, this varies because owning land
doesn’t necessarily mean you own the mineral
rights to it.
In a nutshell, the owner of the respective
mineral rights to a piece of land is entitled
to those substances that could potentially
be sitting below a given property and it’s
not uncommon for them to be sold separately
to land and property rights.
And there have been cases in the past of home-owners
finding out that there is a huge deposit of
gas under their home that they don’t have
rights to, and have no right to stop the owner
of the mineral rights drilling for.
Beyond the loss of money from that gas if
you didn’t own the mineral rights, this
can sometimes kill any property value your
land may have previously had.
However, if you own both the land and all
the mineral rights to a property and you live
in the US, everything below the ground belongs
to you, unless you happen to stumble on an
Indian burial ground or something, in which
case you have to report it.
Other than that, practically everything is
fair game, you can drill for oil and gas or
even mine, assuming you have the relevant
permits, and anything you find is yours to
sell or keep.
However, if something below the ground of
your property extends to the property of someone
else, like a pool of oil or vein of gold,
they have an equal claim to the portion of
the material on their side of property line.
This can get messy very quickly since determining
exact boundaries underground is difficult
and costly, unless you live in the UK, in
which case, the Crown has first dibs on all
coal, oil, silver, gas and gold found on public
or private property.
It should also be noted that in the United
States, thanks to compulsory integration,
gas companies potentially have the right to
drill under your land from an adjacent property
if they have leased or been deeded a certain
percentage of land surrounding your land,
with this percentage varying from state to
state.
As for how much of the land below your property
you own, there’s no real limit enforced
by courts and there have been cases of people
being prosecuted for trespassing on other
people’s property for digging even in the
thousands of feet below the ground in the
search for oil.
Of course, in reality there is a practical
limit in that if there is a country on the
other side of the world from your land, it’s
probably not one where your country has jurisdiction.
Further, there is the matter of the giant
layer of magma inbetween.
But beyond that, you can generally dig away
to your heart’s content as long as you’re
not breaking any environmental laws and have
the appropriate permits.
If you happen to live next to water, your
rights again, vary greatly depending on the
exact situation and it’s covered by a totally
different set of laws and rules called, riparian
rights.
If you have a stream or the like running through
your land, in Britain you’re entitled to
fish while they’re in the water on your
land, but you can’t do anything that would
impede the flow of water to other people’s
land since all running water eventually flows
into the public ocean.
Likewise, if navigable water flows across,
through or otherwise near your property, you’re
not allowed to do anything that would upset
its natural course since the ground beneath
all navigable water is owned by the state,
so the public can use it freely.
If your property borders a large body of water,
on the other hand, in general you have the
right to access the water and if you so wish,
construct a pier or wharf.
However, you have no right to stop people
using the water for navigational purposes
and your rights to the land beneath the water,
if any, only extends to a reasonable level
of depth which has never been precisely defined.
If you happen to own a chunk of non-navigable
water, that’s generally yours to do with
as you please (barring breaking any environmental
laws).
As for animals, you cannot claim ownership
of any wild animals on your land; you are,
however, allowed to hunt them if they’re
not endangered.
Trees, plants and fruit, on the other hand,
are yours to do with as you please as long
as the plant was originally planted or seeded
on your land.
If your neighbour owns any plants or trees
that overhang onto, or the roots spread out
under, your property, you’re within your
rights to trim them back (even the roots)
as long as doing so wouldn’t kill the plant.
However, the original owner still has the
rights to any cuttings and can request that
they be returned after you’ve cut them off.
The same can be said for any fruit that happens
to grow on the tree.
So, technically, taking fruit from such a
branch hanging on your property is theft.
However, any leaves that fall off of the tree
are your problem to deal with, unless they
cause damage to your property (for example
by blocking up your gutters, or in the case
of roots, growing into your septic drainage
field or damaging your house foundation) in
which case, you can ask your neighbour to
pay for the damage and if they refuse, you
can sue and will likely win.